well today is the day to put caramel or
caramel depending on how you say it on
everything including
your popcorn that's right well to
celebrate a few national celebration
days this week rocky theaters hung out
with the popcorn girl herself to get an
inside look on how the sweet and savory
treat
is made right here in las vegas happy
national caramel day and tomorrow happy
national caramel popcorn day so i
figured
we come to a place that you can
celebrate both and that is popcorn girl
here in vegas
you are born and raised here yeah and
you are the popcorn queen
so let's start popping what's going on
here how does it work well first we're
uh our first step in making caramel
popcorn obviously is the pop
popcorn it doesn't just come all out
without farmland right
so here we go out of it you'll see it
it's starting to it's starting to
start to uh come out here whoa
so you're used to making popcorn in your
microwave this is the real deal yeah
so once it pops once it pours out here
then you mix it up here
oh my gosh right here it comes
i love it okay so this is step one step
one what is step two okay so step two is
pour the finished popcorn right in here
and it's cooked it now for five minutes
and now it's gonna come out at that oh
my gosh
have you ever seen fresh caramel popcorn
right out of the what do you call that
thing i don't want to call it a problem
it's a caramelizer it's a caramelizer
and how long does that take how long
does the process take
how long does that take from the time
you put start the cooking of the caramel
the whole process is an
hour an hour you guys this is a serious
operation here they're putting in some
time and some work
yeah into your caramel popcorn so so now
he's got to separate it or it'll stick
together
okay so we get those this very popcorn
was that i don't like yeah right you
want each little
each little little kernel yeah yeah okay
i love it okay so let's talk about the
caramel itself because that's
what today is all about and what
tomorrow's all about what goes into the
perfect caramel recipe
well i know we have the ingredients over
here yes it's going to be
butter brown sugar some sugar and some
vanilla
okay okay uh this is you know
just you can't fail yeah yeah i know you
can't fill it with brown sugar and
butter
like vanilla right who does this because
this is unique to popcorn girl because
sometimes you just use the
something to use just powdered caramel
yes this is what separates you guys
that's right in fact when you buy these
cookers they come with
you know powdered caramel and you just
throw it right away ah
this that's not right i'm gonna use the
real premium stuff here okay coming up
later
we're gonna talk about the other flavors
that popcorn girl has to offer because
it is a long
unique menu which i love all right so
we'll stay tuned for
that oh my god my mouth is
watery oh